Howie Mandel was on our show on Monday
and he told a story about losing his
iPhone in an uber car it's pretty
interesting take a look past that
I flew in from Spokane Washington and I
took an uber home my phone is in the
uber Mike it's not funny my phone is in
the hueber his name is David and he's
driving a Honda Accord and he has you
have my phone do you have my phone okay
well here's the nice thing I'm happy to
report that because how he told the
story on our show the uber driver saw it
got in touch with Howie and returned his
lost iPhone it's an incredible story
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh you have no idea how exciting this is
for me tell us exactly how you retrieve
the phone okay you came on the show and
I love it okay well I'm not good I left
the it's my fault I left it in your car
you were doing your job you really but
then you left I called the uber nobody
answered in uber right I tweeted uber
support I got no supports I was on
Instagram I was on Twitter I finally
came to Conan yeah and all I did was
show David's picture David I showed your
picture and what happened David what
happened stop yelling at him how wait no
yeah somebody saw it right yeah they
called you they do and you returned my
phone yes I did you not only returned my
phone we got closer you asked me yeah
for a job yeah listen we'll get to that
later my point is this was such a
heartwarming story it gave me an idea
see we've been looking for a real
purpose for this show for like 24 years
yeah I think we found it that's right
celebrity lost and found
[Applause]
if you're a celebrity and you've lost an
item contact us at celebrity
lost-and-found at gmail.com for example
if you're Emma Stone and you lost your
Kindle charger on a city bus contact us
if you're Vin Diesel and you lost your
signed copy of gravity's rainbow bike
Thomas Pynchon contact us if you're Gary
Busey and you lost your bag of human
hair contact us but don't take it from
me take it from celebrity Howie Mandel
Howie
thanks to celebrity lost-and-found
I didn't have to send my assistant to
the Apple store to buy a new iPhone and
charge it to my credit card account
thanks Conan
no problem
[Applause]
you